what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am going
to be reacting to
adam 22 freaks out over brain dead
woman's viral dating advice
um before i start do not forget to
subscribe
to the channel and bring that
notification bell
while you're at it leave a comment
um let me know the worst dating advice
that you have ever
heard okay podcast of fresh and fit
podcasts talk to them today we uh
we i tuned into this clip because you
know everybody's been telling us that we
gotta [ __ ] with them because they have
kind of a popping podcast coming out of
miami i believe
and um there's one clip in particular
it's like six minutes long up
i don't know this is one of the only
clips i watched on their podcast but
it's
a couple of dudes [ __ ] 10 girls all
sitting at this table
i can't even imagine what this podcast
would be like if we had 10 girls hitting
here
and that's most of their content right
they have girls all the time
and they talk about it and like i said
kevin samuels he calls in all the time
but
usually there's like six or seven women
at the table and they ask questions and
they go back and forth
so shout out to fresh and fit they be
kicking girls out all the [ __ ] time
really
yes all the [ __ ] time that's awesome
yeah they do because they bring in the
trashiest women
they kick girls all the time because
some of them get real like kevin samuels
roasted one of the feminists on there
they had i think i saw that [ __ ] he
went on that that was like that
like a blonde yeah i think
yeah he [ __ ] destroyed her bro wow
kevin samuels broke her to [ __ ] check
that out because this girl i know
hit me up when i posted a clip of my
story of
one of his the viral clip i posted the
clip this girl i know hits me up she
goes
[ __ ] you for not tagging me in that clip
she's one of the girls in the team i'm
like
you seriously think that i was looking
at all the [ __ ] girls there enough to
like
did they even cross my mind that i might
know these people stay at the table
anyway
so there's this guy mr organic who uh
[ __ ] i recently
touched down with on instagram and he
has a green beard
which is something that i might have to
experiment with myself i've never
thought about dying my beard but there's
a lot of gray in it now at this point so
if i show up looking like i got [ __ ]
ecto cooler in my beard
you'll know what's going on anyway he's
sitting there mr organic we're talking
about fresh and fit right now buddy
you know about them though fresh and fit
podcast hell yeah okay so
in miami right so he's sitting there and
he's given a little bit of a lecture for
whatever reason
about the kind of woman that a guy who
apparently he's pretty successful or
at least he seems to feel very
successful the way he's talking about
himself
basically saying at a certain point as a
guy once you become successful or
whatever
that you want more from a woman than
what a basic ass dude wants from a woman
a basic guy's dude might just want a hot
girl that he could take to the club once
you get to a certain level
all of a sudden you're looking at a hot
girl you can just take the club and
you're thinking like that's not a
million to you like he was basically
saying i've had money and
been in business for a long time so i'm
not impressed by the same [ __ ] that a
lot of guys are
this girl really feels like she knows
something and she starts responding to
him in the clip and telling him
men only successful men all they want
from a woman i think of the quote
is for her to bring inspiration to the
table
aka cooking wearing lingerie
providing him with sex etc
i i wish i had a heart monitor on when i
was watching this clip
because it made me so [ __ ] mad
because a lot of girls just think they
can just
be girls
and that's like enough for a guy that
this [ __ ] has actually been misled her
whole entire life
but she's right all these guys want from
her
is to basically just be a sex object
right because
you're a [ __ ] idiot and you have
nothing else to offer you look okay
sure but you have nothing going on
between your [ __ ] ears
and she's just telling this guy that
that's how the world is and he's sitting
there telling her
no when you get to this point in your
life you want somebody that you're going
to be able to build something with that
you're going to feel
inspired by that that's going to be yeah
she's the inspiration yeah but
she means like oh my gosh she literally
wants to like sit on the couch in
lingerie and make you i guess
make more money trading chris most of
their content she wants to be able to
call herself a muse on something
she is not most of their content is
women who think like that
and they get into it back and forth it's
like i would say
the younger version of of women that
kevin samuels talks to
that's that's what it's just like i
don't want enough of this and that's the
thing like
you can live that lifestyle um like the
fast life in miami whatever but
at some point it's going to catch up to
you sooner or later it's a real judgment
it seems like there unless you're lucky
some people
some people it doesn't but i guarantee
for every one person it doesn't there's
five that it does
kind of doing the thing that kevin
samuels does where you get these girls
and you actually find out what they're
really thinking but instead of getting
like
you know kevin samuels demographic is
kind of like grown ass black women that
are past their prime and are
wondering why they can't get into a
relationship these guys seem like
they're really getting the
the hoes from the club to just come sit
on this podcast
and that's one thing that you never
really realize when you're in the club
and you're looking around you're seeing
all these hot girls
you might not realize that they're all
idiots
and yeah you could barely have a [ __ ]
fourth grade conversation with them
because that's what i got out of
watching that clip it's like
these guys are giving voice to the
really good looking women that have a
[ __ ] iq
of like 14. and one i've seen a lot of
girls when they're like younger they're
like smart and driven but
then they just get handed so much stuff
in their life is just so easy that
by the time they're like 25 and
everything starts to fade or 27 whatever
it is
like they haven't had to like do
anything because they've just been paid
for
and taken care of the whole time i've
seen like i've seen one that was
mind-blowing to me right
so they're talking to this girl and
she's like uh
yeah my guy that i was with right he
cheated on me so much he cheated on me
with five of my friends or something
like that
[ __ ] guy yeah and i'm like
self-respect i'm like this is a pretty
girl too
and then basically they break down like
well was he was he paying for everything
like yeah okay he paid for her to go to
school and once she was done with school
she was like okay i don't have like need
you no more so it was like basically
you let him cheat on you with [ __ ] uh
with five of your friends and he was
putting you through school as soon as
you
graduated school you didn't want to do
that [ __ ] no more it was cool
and then then on top of that she was did
she just pretend she didn't
see it i hate to say i would be okay
if someone cheated on me with five of my
friends
and girl you want to use him for school
like
is it the right thing i can't really he
cheated on her with five of her friends
saying yeah well i did but i probably
wouldn't stay
that long four years one for a year i
don't want a guy to like
you know basically judge her because she
only did porn but you have to realize
that people judge you for everything
so even if people judge you for not
doing stuff people judge you for
doing stuff people judge you for the way
you talk like
you're constantly being judged for your
actions and your words
she doesn't do it no more and bro is
like what the [ __ ] of course a guy is
going to judge you off of that [ __ ] you
know i mean
i'm pro-sex worker so i
don't think i should maybe be like
judging girls as harshly for that but
yeah obviously
when you're doing porn you also are just
accepting that there's like a cultural
reality of how a lot of guys are going
to act about that how a lot of jobs are
going to act about that you got to be
ready for that but most of the guys that
be
like it like for me having a lot of home
girls and i talk to them about these
type of situations
most of the guys that these women seem
to encounter and they have these
problems
with our guys that have absolutely
nothing to bring to the table too
it'll be bum ass hobo and that's why
some
people will say it's all about money but
i've seen girls stamp like
hard for guys that literally are broke
both sexual ass [ __ ] that just be
[ __ ] the home girls to have somewhere
to stay
you feel me and like they'd be the most
controlling of like oh why are you
wearing this why you got this many guy
friends why are you did it
and it's just at the end of the day it
comes down to like an insecurity thing
and i feel like a lot of
men if we like i mean
we all at this table i could say are
probably in a different predicament than
like
you know a guy that's like down bad and
just happens to like look up on the girl
that has a lot of money and like
popularity or whatever those are the
guys that be the most insecure
that be trying to control they [ __ ]
because they
don't got it and see this is what i was
offering this is what i was telling
yazzy earlier is that because they bring
nothing to the table so
they just can sense that she's she's
going to leave
women maine i'm sorry i wish you could
actually play like a recording of what
you were actually saying to yassie where
you're just like
you date blah blah blah you were just
like telling her your friends are ugly
like
no no no i don't know i didn't say your
friends in the other room no
no she said that that she don't like but
she didn't like the way
kevin samuels um portray and how he
talks right
so i said okay if i i'd use the same
analogy with yuri
i said if yuri said hey i want a girl
like kim kardashian right now and i'm
not gonna get with somebody
until i get that and if i told him hey
yuri you're out of your [ __ ] mind and
think you're gonna get kim kardashian
i said is that being mean she's like no
so i said so what's the difference
of telling a woman who looks not very
attractive
who doesn't have a lot going for herself
that she's going to get a man that makes
seven
figures okay i agree but i
also can tell you why it hurts women's
feelings more because a man can always
change his income a woman can't change
the face
that she was born with that's in the top
10 well unless you want to
get plastic surgery but i don't even
think that looks good how fast of all
men
it doesn't make no [ __ ] sense and
that's basically what i was
trying to tell her i'm like hey you got
home girls that you call yourself
that they're not attractive right she's
like yeah and they said yeah so and they
they have thoughts that they're going to
get a [ __ ] like poo scheiste or
something like that like
she says yeah i have to tell them all
the time you won't get them exactly so
what's
the difference between a man telling you
that and somebody else tells you bad and
just horny as [ __ ]
and i also said that women equate guys
for the most part
based off what we can provide for them
hell yeah
and that's why if you think about it
like with yuri like
yuri is as a guy yuri's
looks are not holding him back if yuri
had
10 million dollars his looks immediately
are not
whatever but then meanwhile for like you
know if you're
i don't know who yuri is with a woman
it's kind of it's not really like that
if like a woman has 10 million dollars
and she looks like
rosie o'donnell oh [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of
rosie me too yeah but you're a [ __ ]
like that's the thing he says i would
[ __ ] the [ __ ] out of her not marry her
you're really trying to date her live
off a girl though you're trying to use
every part of the buffalo
and that's and that's the thing that's
weird i never heard that enough people
oh my god that's you it's like i'm not
just using your [ __ ] i'm gonna use your
whip
i'm gonna use your couch i'm gonna jerk
off these tissues
i got my own couch yeah because use more
okay and
let's say you're a great guy right and
let's look look what society is did
right
you have a song like no scrubs tlc made
i don't want no scrub
sitting on your best friend's ride right
you can be a great guy going through
hard times and you're telling
you're telling women don't [ __ ] with
that guy and then you got songs now
bro it'd be so many tweets and girls be
like yeah like like
[ __ ] want you to hold them down like
on their way up like i'll see you at the
top like yeah
like i won't even give you that chance
until you're already there but when it's
reversed but that you also have to
realize
that a lot of times
girls will stay with a guy till he makes
it to the top and then he'll cheat on
her when he gets there
so it's like she's stuck by you for all
those years so like jeff bezos
bezos's wife like she stuck by him for
all of those years
and then when he got to the top he just
decided to cheat on her
and then the man of sphere like
criticizes her for leaving
but they they in the middle spirits
where they like think guys have a right
to cheat just because they have money
person we say
we don't want a woman that we have to
build up it's like oh you're the [ __ ]
devil
oh that's [ __ ] wrong oh that's that
and that's basically what i was telling
jazzy i'm like
the message the way that he does it may
not be the best way
because it comes off as mean but he's
telling
i actually don't mind the way i've
actually probably said
at some point that i don't like the way
kevin samuels talks but the more i think
about it
the more i actually don't mind it so
much they call into a show they know
what they're signing up for the truth
and until people get a fix of reality
they're gonna be in [ __ ] up situations
and a lot of women the the shocking
thing to them about kevin samuels
content is that
okay here is some content here's an
arena an environment
in which you're not going to get treated
like a victim and i think
so many women in american culture are
just not used to that because they're
completely used to
never being held accountable or being at
fault
and so to see a guy actually say like no
like you're not a victim and actually
you're going to be judged on your own
merits just like men
at least while we're on this show is
unbelievably shocking to them yeah and
the thing is
is like what boston oversaid he said you
don't have to call
in so if everything is going right in
your life and you're getting these men
that you so called one why are you even
calling in to get advice from me anyway
when you already know what i'm about to
say
i've seen some girls call in and say
that that kevin samuels is right
because you're not getting that and you
don't understand why
yeah i mean i think that most of the
women calling in are
kind of acknowledging that there's
something wrong they just also
don't want to be held accountable for it
and they all think
that they're going to be the one to out
argue
kevin samuels even though i don't know
people always want me to call and do a
show
but that's i get scared sometimes i'm
not even gonna lie i probably will at
some point
but i get nervous pretty much like based
his entire life around being able to win
this argument
and he talks them in the same way
um i enjoyed this reaction i thought it
was interesting
to hear like other people react to
freshman fix i have the same
thoughts when i hear some of the girls
talk like that they're just idiots
but let me know in the comments if you
agree or you disagree and do not forget
to subscribe to the channel as you guys
know trying to hit 20 000 subscribers
and ring that notification bell while
you're at it to get daily videos i'll
talk to you guys next time